Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Today's video is coming to you in three very
special parts: business, exciting announcements,
and mosquito-borne illnesses.
Part one- business.
So Hank, in last week's video, I asked people
if we should turn on pre-roll advertisements
for Vlogbrothers, and then, if so, what we
should do with that revenue.
Tens of thousands of people responded, Hank,
and they voted overwhelmingly that we should
turn on pre-rolls and that we should split
the income between the Foundation to Decrease
World Suck, and a fund that will help out
educational video projects.
So that's what we're going to do, and Nerdfighters,
we will keep you up to date on how that money
is spent.
By the way Hank, did you notice that I have
a tan?
I've been experimenting a little bit with
outside, although I can't, in good faith,
recommend it.
Also I've got some puff because I'm in control
of my own haircut schedule for the first time
in six months.
People in Hollywood have lots of opinions
about how often you should get a haircut.
Part two- exciting announcement.
Sooo I am going to East Africa with Bill Gates.
I am very excited about this trip, not only
because I get to hang out with Bill Gates,
but also because I get to meet a lot of people
who are doing important work in health and
agriculture.
And hopefully I'm going to learn a lot and
make a bunch of videos.
But that brings me to part three- mosquito-borne
illnesses.
The light keeps changing; it's like a 2007
Vlogbrothers video.
So Hank, as you know some of my anxiety problems
center on physical health, and when my doctor
was giving me the vaccines to get ready for
this trip, he said "You should read the CDC
web pages about the places you'll be visiting",
and that was a terrible idea.
Because those websites are like, "malaria
mosquitoes bite mostly at night-time, while
yellow fever mosquitoes bite primarily during
the day, and West Nile mosquitoes bite at
dawn and dusk."
And reading that stuff made me think I am
going to a place where disease-ridden mosquitoes
bite in shifts.
So I called my doctor and I was like, "This
doesn't seem safe at all", and he said, "You
should read the Indiana State Department of
Health webpage"!
So I did, and in addition to having information
about the West Nile virus, which I knew to
be worried about, there was a warning about
the Arbo virus, which I'd never even heard
of.
And one about Chikungunya virus which I don't
even know how to pronounce.
Hank, I don't want to be killed by something
that I can't pronounce!
I think my doctor thought I would emerge from
that experience less anxious, but quite the
opposite.
Anyway Hank, all of this is just to say that
I've recently become, I think, the only person
in the history of the world to read the entire
Indiana State Department of Health website.
No, wait, I also had another point, which
is that we have excellent healthcare facilities
and information here in the United States.
We've got great infrastructure, the power
very rarely goes off in health clinics, and
all that stuff helps us to deal with mosquito-borne
illnesses and other communicable diseases
relatively effectively.
And I'm going to East Africa, Hank, to see
how they've dramatically improved healthcare
and reduced infant mortality in the last twenty
years.
And also to see how much work there still
is to be done and where we can help.
I'm gonna make a bunch of videos, but they
probably won't be uploaded during my trip,
so in the meantime I'm going to make a video
about Behind the Beautiful Forevers, the Nerdfighter
Book Club pick for summer.
If you haven't read it, now's the time because
A) it will make next week's video more enjoyable,
and B)
it's excellent.
It won the Pulitzer Prize, for God's sakes.
But anyway yeah, I will schedule that video
to upload next Tuesday so that I don't get
punished.
Speaking of punishments, Hank, you owe us
one!
Nerdfighters, I need punishment suggestions
for Hank in the comments.
Hank, DFTBA, I will see you on Friday.